So in the synoptic gospels um they it
says that they celebrated the Passover
before they before Christ was crucified
and then in the gospel of John it says
that
>> yeah there was no contradiction
>> I have an article on this by Lisa Archer
he already answered this ages ago him as
well as
>> I'll get you the article on he's talking
about when on the eve of Passover Jesus
was betrayed it was the eve of Passover
but John says that when he was
crucified, they were slaughtering the
Passover lambs. Now, understand what
he's trying to say. If John is saying
when Jesus was taken to be crucified,
they were slaughtering Passover's lambs,
right? That means the eve of the
Passover
would have been
that day. You get what he's trying to
say here? Because you prepared the lambs
for the eve of the Passover. So,
understand what the objection is. Okay?
I'm going to show you the article. I
want everyone understand when you read
John 19:14,
you'll see they were slaughtering the
lambs. Well, that means the evil
Passover would have been that day
because you slaughtered the lambs to
then eat them at night. But the
synoptics say Jesus was already
observing the Passover meal the day
before. Hold on. So, if he's observing
it on Thursday, that means they would
have already slaughtered the Passover
lambs earlier. But John says when he's
crucified, that's when they slaughtered
the Passover lambs. So, is there a
contradiction? No. Because it turns out
that
it wasn't just on the evil Passover they
slaughter lambs. They did it also the
subsequent day. Let me just get the
article. This was already answered ages
ago. Yeah, this was answered ages ago.
>> But again, I got to find it. There's no
cont. This was already resolved by the
way by scholars ages ago, Gleon L Archer
and also
another scholar who harmonized the
gospel. I believe it's at Robertson.
Harmony the gospels. He already
addressed it thoroughly. But do you
think that modern scholars acknowledge
the harmonizations? No. You even have
evangelicals pretty much saying, "Yeah,
John changed the date for theological
purposes."
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's what I've been saying
to even like evangelical Christians are
like leaning on the liberalistic more
explanations.
>> So guys, wait, let me find it. I got to
find it. Okay, crucifixion. All right,
now let's go through it. It's short to
the point. So, a contradiction often
raised by skeptics and Rumble. Here you
go. Here it is for you. See, God has
answered all the objections, brothers
and sisters. God has answered all the
objections.
But if you don't want the answers, and
he's not going to give you the answers
if you made up your mind. A
contradiction often raised by skeptics,
whether Muslims or others, centers on
the day Christ was crucified. The
synoptic gospels i.e. Matthew, Mark, and
Luke stated that Christ was crucified on
Friday, the day after Passover Eve. John
on the other hand seems imply that
Christ was crucified on the day before
on Thursday or that he's saying that he
was crucified on the Friday which was
the time of the Passover so that it
wasn't Thursday. Either way we have
decided to quote the late Dr. Gleason L
Archer's entire response from his book
Encyclopedia Bible Difficulties since he
does a masterful job of showing that no
real contradiction exists between these
accounts. short to the point. But guys,
you want me to go through it? You guys
okay if I go through this?
I know you're okay, right? You want me
to go through this?
>> Definitely, brother. That's why I'm
asking the question.
>> Well, you got the link, too. So, all
right. The uniform impression conveyed
by the synoptic gospels, right?
>> Is that the crucifixion took place on
Friday of Holy Week? Meaning, so if he
celebrated evil of Passover Thursday,
Friday he was slaughtered. If it were
not for John 19:14, the point would
never have come up for debate. But John
19:14 says according to American Senate
Bible, not was the day of preparation.
That's how you would pronounce if you're
Greek. But if you're seeing it way,
parasui
parasi
for the Passover to prepare for the
Passover. Okay, watch.
It was about the sixth hour. And he said
to the Jews, "Behold your king." The NIV
suggests a somewhat less difficult
handling of the apparent discrepancy. It
was the day of preparation of Passover
week about the sixth hour. So if you go
with that Jesus was crucified on the day
of preparation, that means Passover had
begun. You're preparing for Passover.
But the synoptics say he was eating the
Passover meal. They had already prepared
for it. Contradiction. No. You
understand what he's saying? No. Because
this word peski
doesn't necessarily imply they're
preparing for the evil Passover. Watch
here.
Watch here. Now, this latter translation
takes note of two important very
important matters of uses usage. First,
the word paraske had already by the
first century AD become a technical term
for Friday. He's right. And the dedicay
it says you fast
on the fourth day and day of
preparation. Do you know that? Okay
guys, please listen to the answer. I'm
going to do an entire session and title
it unless someone clips this.
At the time of our Lord, Friday was
called preparation day. para skevi if
you read the dedicay
and you read chapter 8 you're told in
Greek celebrate your fast on the fourth
day and
preparation day paraske
everyone with me there
the word Friday the day Friday was
called pariskei because that's the day
they would prepare for Sabbath Friday
then Friday evening Sabbath you can't do
anything okay everyone got it
so is this saying that the Lord was
crucified on the preparation for the
Passover week or the preparation for
Sabbath.
Why? Because though Passover week
started Thursday evening, that means the
next day Friday, they would still have
to prepare for the Sabbath.
>> So in other words, there are two
preparations day days. The preparation
for the Passover on Thursday and the
preparation for Sabbath on Friday.
Okay,
everyone got it?
Okay. So which parasi is it referring
to? So now watch second the Greek term
tof pasa of the Passover is taken to be
equivalent to the Passover week. They
would use the word Passover for entire
week because if you guys don't know
Passover lasts seven days 14th of Nissan
to the 21st
rumble you're getting this 14th of
Nissan to the 21st. Curse is everyone
getting it? So you would call that the
Passover.
This refers to the seven-day feast of
unleven bread, masot, that immediately
followed the initial slaughtering and
eating of the Passover lamb on the
evening of the 14th day of the month,
Abib, which by Hebrew reckoning would
mean the commencement of the 15th day
right after sunset. The week of massot
coming right after on the heels of
Passover itself during which masot were
each actually eaten along with the lamb
bitter herbs etc very naturally came to
be known as Passover week.
So once the Passover begins, it's called
Passover week, right? So now watch here.
Extending from the 15th to the 21st of
Abib inclusively and he's giving you the
lexical scholarly references. That's
right. State this art and Gingrich state
this Passover was followed immediately
by the fast of unleven bread on the 15th
to 21st. Popular usage merged the two
festivals and treat them as a unity as
they were for practical purposes. Now
watch. It was unnecessary to insert a
specific term for week such as Shabuah.
You didn't need to say that. You just
say Passover began. All right. That
means now we have to celebrate from 14th
to the 21st.
Everyone got it?
Okay.
So here is the answer.
Therefore, that which might be
translated preparation of the Passover
must in the context be rendered Friday
of Passover week. They're not preparing
for Passover to begin. It already began.
But this is the Friday that fell under
the commencement of Passover week. It
already started. So it's really the
preparation for Sabbath.
And turns out therefore that John
affirms just as clearly as the synoptics
that Christ was crucified on Friday and
that a sacrificial death represented an
antiypical
fulfillment of the Passover Passover
ordinance itself because the lambs
pointed him which was instituted by God
in the days of the Exodus as a means of
making Calvary available by faith to the
ancient people of God even before the
coming of Christ. So he's saying there's
no contradiction. So let me explain what
he's saying. Passover week began that
Thursday evening. That Friday being a
high Sabbath, right? The Lord is going
to be crucified when Passover has
commenced, but still it's the day to
prepare for Sabbath and it's still the
Passover week.
So you can still say that the Lord was
crucified on the day of Parisvi
because Parisi
would mean preparing. Preparing for
what? Preparing for Sabbath and also at
the same time Passover the term was used
to refer for the entire period that
lasted seven days. Everyone got what
he's saying?
Do you understand what he's saying
there?
Or we lost you, Samuel, because I can't
hear you.
>> I'm here. I'm here. No, I'm
understanding. Wow.
>> Now, watch what he says. Then note that
in 1 Corinthians 5:7, Jesus is referred
to as the Passover lamb for the
believers. All right. The statement of
EC Hoskins on John 19:14 is very
appropriate here. The hour of the double
sacrifice is drawing near. It is midday.
The Passover lambs are being prepared
for sacrifice, and the lamb of God is
likewise sentenced to death.
It simply needs to be pointed out that
the lambs referred to here are not those
that were slaughtered and eaten in
private homes. All right. Jesus had
already observed with his disciples the
night before, Monday, Thursday, but the
lambs to be offered on the altar of the
Lord on behalf of the whole nation of
Israel. Meaning, you know, morning and
evening sacrifices for the household of
service on the evening of the 14th of
Abib. Compare following Exodus 12:6. I
don't know why I said Nissan, but
anyway. For the public sacrifice on the
altar, compare following Exodus
12:16-17,
Leviticus 23:4 to8, 2 Chronicles
30:15-19,
35 11-6. Now, let me explain what he's
saying.
On the eve of Passover, each household
will slaughter their own lamb and eat
it. But the next day, the priest would
slaughter Passover lambs for the altar
in the temple as well as morning evening
sacrifices. They're referring to two
slaughters. The one each household does
where they slaughter lamb and eat it and
the ones the priests do to offer it on
the altar in the temple.
So John is talking about the lambs that
the priests would have slaughtered in
the temple the next day. Not to the lamb
a household was slaughtered to eat in
their private homes.
Making sense now?
>> Yep. Definitely.
>> These were all known as Passover
sacrifices since they were presented
during the Passover week. So they would
constantly sacrifice lambs for that week
on the altar in the temple. But the lamb
that they would eat in their private
homes they did on that evening was what
Jesus would have done. But then the next
day the lambs on the altars would be
slaughtered by the priest which is not
that which they ate but slaughtered on
the altars in the temple. And that's
what John is referring to.
Wow. And here it says, "Thus it turns
out that there has been a simple
misunderstanding of the phrase
that has occasion such perplexity that
even Guthrie deduce an urgent error.
Even this guy thought it was error for
which he had no solution offer the
various ingenuous explanations offered
by others that Christ held his personal
Passover a night early, knowing that
he'd be crucified before the evening of
the 14th. that Christ and his movement
held it to a different calendar. That's
what they say. That John was going by
the Essen calendar, reckoning the 14th
to be a day earlier than the calendar of
the official Jerusalem priesthood or he
was following a revised calendar
observed by the Essenes at Kuman. All
these theories are quite improbable and
altogether unnecessary.
There is no contradiction whatsoever
between John and the synoptics as the
day in which Christ died. It was Friday.
Now, what does that mean? Let me sum it
up.
On the eve of Passover, people prepare
their personal lamb. Each household
finds a lamb, kills it, cooks it, eats
it. Now begins the Passover week. The
Passover week was called Pasa and that
lasted from the 14th to 21st. There
would celebrate unle bread. During that
time, the priest would then slaughter
lambs for the Passover week and offer
them on the altar in the temple along
with the morning evening sacrifices. So
when John says that our Lord is being
crucified on
Pasca, it's not talking about the
personal lamb that each household ate.
It's talking about the priests preparing
lambs to be slaughtered for the Passover
week that lasts seven days.
So where's the contradiction?
>> There's no contradiction.
>> There you go.
>> I've always heard I've I've heard people
trying to um explain it away with the
what he just said recently. Uh what um
about calendars.
>> Yeah. But this one, this one is like,
this one, it really clearly lays it out.
>> Yep. And got here, uh, Rumble, here's
the article. Sorry. So, this why I say
98% of the objections, not 99, have
already been answered on Answering Islam
or on my blog. Why? Because these were
objections I got hit with. Glory to the
triune God. Glory to the Father, Holy
Spirit. The spirit guided me to these
resources and I found the answers for
you. I didn't know by writing them that
now it would help people for live
streams because look how easy it is. You
don't need to go do the research. Just
go to the blogs, upload them, save them,
pray. These sites last for hundreds of
years if the Lord is pleased. It's
there.
>> It's there.
>> Glory to God. And he and he used it for
the greater good. Amen.